foreign
[Music]
that's not a knife this is a knife oh
crocodile hey Greg talk to me I'm
talking to you no talk to me I am
talking I'm trying to talk to you okay
well that's the name of the movie today
we're watching talk to me it's an a24
movie we love 824 I know literally not
one thing about this you know more than
me I I know I love what I know and I'd
like to share what I know okay talk to
me I'm not gonna talk about what the
actual movie is but the filmmakers
behind it oh they do have a YouTube
channel called rackaracka it's a great
Channel like in their careers trajectory
to that of like Jordan peel when it
comes to Key and Peele to get out they
do these like crazy wild kinetic
sketches that are very mature that you
can see how well they encapsulate their
knowledge of genre so well to see them
go from sketch comedy on YouTube to then
doing a horror film to a24 I'm like no
that makes perfect sense so I've been a
big fan of their work for a very very
very long time this is the first movie
I'm watching where I'm proud of the
filmmakers behind it even though I
haven't seen it wow damn you said it's
mature we're also very mature
[Music]
to make a fart noise when I said machine
yeah I didn't if you think we're mature
like this video comment subscribe all
that good stuff and if you are a super
sexy reject over on patreon and you get
our full-length Reaction watch long
where you sync up with your own copy as
for the super sexy rejects only for the
very sexy sexy people whoa how'd you do
that the Rave glow stick move
nope yeah I didn't do it yeah I learned
when I was young my friend Yong Chong
taught me it you go slow am I doing it
nope most people do this wait wait what
are you doing if you get when you know
like a Raves when you glow sticks
very specific movement Greg you're good
at everything including you and yeah
including raving and you and John
covering several shows over there
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watchalongs included shall we stop
talking to them and talk to me yeah it's
gonna talk to you the whole movie Roxy
yeah that would be that's usually what
we do yeah we get all the stars that's
not how YouTube works there's not Stars
just back and forth will improve
you're talking about
you do this while do it slow sorry
oh I'm excited this is the most excited
I've seen you for a movie yeah
boy boy
oh yes
that's not nice
[Music]
do you think the actor actually had to
do that yeah it looks like it they're in
here oh I'm gonna take you home okay bro
I'm upset you're gonna hurt a lot of
people
Mommy
this is a hell of an opening shot they
haven't cut yet is it a horror movie
yeah are you serious
put your phones down
are they recording him bastards kill
them
the brother just stabbed the other
brother yeah
he's on drugs I have no idea
that's not a knife this is a knife
this is predicted the whole movie I
predicted the whole thing wow did you
think those were gonna be our two main
characters
oh because I saw the poster okay because
I thought those were gonna be our two
main characters and I was just about to
talk about how much I liked them I feel
like the dynamic tease
the psychological torture of what's to
come for our actual main character is
she related to them
you talk to me as if I know
the ins and outs of the plot just made
it a moment
your auntie wants to talk to you
talk to me
Craig I'm begging talk to me I should
call her name in contacts wow and like
stayed on that blur shot
it's a technical term I pulled the word
well
you're getting the cold
uh yeah I think so I love her hair how
was today for you
fine
and her earrings and her costume feel
like we have a really good read of
character right now it's interesting
they kept the dad blurred this whole
time again that word blur keeps coming
back in my brain Focus defocus all right
we'll just call Riley she doesn't work
up all right yeah and have fun with you
cancer so you feed us
foreign
[Music]
it's fun seeing an actual bonding
between like caretaker babysitter
I don't know I think they see something
oh no dear
oh it's kangaroo do we call a vet Mr
gonna help Riley I mean look at it oh
this is so sad can you at least put it
out of its misery
no put it out of its misery what are you
gonna do run over it I think so but then
she's gonna get arrested it's illegal to
kill kangaroos do you know that oh I
don't want oh no no I don't know that
I'm just talking out of my ass talk to
me too out of my ass
I mean I know we can't leave it like
this another car woke up
Mia is crying interesting I wonder if
there's gonna be like consequences to
that choice of not putting it out of its
misery Greg they're driving on the wrong
side of the road yeah a little bunch of
morons all you dummies in Australia too
gosh Greg oh
Riley
[Music]
thanks for picking up me all good
come on oh God what is the dynamic here
hmm
lovers and sisters
it's just how you like it perfect
fantasy come to life this happens when
two men direct I'm doing it again
tonight
not tonight it was mum's two years I
just want to forget about it I think
they're just friends why does she keeps
saying mom like it's their mom but they
were like flirting
I'm a bad persons who
can break a mirror
I wonder if we can get some body horror
stuff I think the main actress is very
natural she doesn't like overplay the
the sadness or anything like that it
feels like a real person who's grieving
it's real natural performance when
you're sneaking out good to see Daniel
all right even if it was he's Ultra
Christian he doesn't do anything at all
he's still
[Laughter]
how could I say no to him whatever
the best friends and her mom took her in
that's the impression I'm getting you oh
I'm dating two apparently me
like all of these three kids all of them
are really good I even think the
dialogue did you sound like actual
people talking I like the little boy
it's just a weird sentence to say it's
okay you're a woman he probably likes
hearing that that's a weird sentence to
say
I mean I think he's very good music
house just yeah
this reoccurring theme of Disconnect
dude why'd you have to bring him
what's wrong with her I think she's just
a Debbie Downer now she's flirting with
your boy
they're friends Haley
you keep telling yourself that
wow
I guess uh other fish yeah you always go
first that's my house would you
would you like this and why I don't know
I think they're doing a possession
testing I'll do it
like from what they were seeing on The
Tick Tock videos
yeah uh I guess it depends on this like
a Ouija board kind of thing I'm not sure
yet I like how they haven't fully told
us yet it's a nice tension to it they
really throw you into this hands up
this must have been a very strange
script on paper what happens after 90
seconds
don't want to stay
oh that's what happened with the guy who
stabbed his brother I guess so oh dude
trust me
It's gotta be time
I like how it's been so handheld and now
it's getting like still and focused
okay Maya
put your hand on it
now say icky talk to me
talk to me
whoa
[Music]
come on man it's different every time
you're gonna say I let you in no I'm
flipping out seriously shut up no
someone was sitting there I swear
I don't go prove it prove it that's why
I say it
[Music]
like just seeing kids take it in with
such Glee yeah the recording of like
other people's downfalls and Trauma is
just so disturbing
getting like a high out of it it was
crazy
[Applause]
okay I let you in
talk to me
weird say it
I let you in I let you in
someone coming got it
whoa
whoa there you are cool Distortion of
audio
[Laughter]
oh this is so uncomfortable I hate this
Jesus
I like you
what oh not you there
are they keeping track of the time I
don't know okay it's 90 seconds it feels
like
cool very Sam Raby
he's behind you now
83 seconds Josh
hurry
help him run run run run run run run
oh man
I think they're gonna get it off I don't
think so no I do but
it's like way past the 90 second Mark
now I don't know they said 83 seconds
seven seconds
seven seconds you're in a bit over
amazing
wow treating it like a drug trip
oh this is so Sinister now she's being
like loved oh no are you gonna be okay
if we never understand how they did that
we got a whole movie to find out I know
I know some things might be a little bit
better left uh unexplained I thought
that was a really well shot sequence too
I wonder if we like played it back if it
would be exactly 90 seconds I'm sure or
however runny they said they went a
little over so because sometimes when
they do sequences like that they tend to
be under over there's no way that they
act that up can I hang with you
to the house bro
so she's obviously on the fritz with her
dad so she's staying with them and it's
like a surrogate sibling situation and
then thanks Kate I'm gonna have a
nightmares Riley
is it her talking or the thing
possessing her probably a little bit of
the thing because then over the 90
seconds I'm looking in the mirror my
reflection is gone like I don't
know anything oh what does the hand feel
like it felt amazing it felt like I was
glowing
feels like a Supernatural episode of
Black Mirror took too many sleeping
pills
accident
really intriguing Dynamic oh my God
crastophobia is a constipation okay and
I feel like everybody has that right
hi is Jade home how'd they get their
hands on that hand you better not be
having a party Jade I swear to God it's
two friends can you let him in
what time is everyone getting here
getting here for what the party is there
a party tonight don't me have
you got alcohol in your car oh no I
don't drink it's Market you're good
mom what time's the party again
more party the party
party tonight what time is it party mom
not drinking tonight on God I will punch
you in the face
[Laughter]
the boyfriend wants to do it it's the
hand of a psychic got cut off in them
legit it's a medium just
but if you smash it there's an actual a
hand in there
everyone around him thought Mrs cut his
hand off white people man I tell
you I'm stoked we got an explanation
film me
all right time
with unknown forces things can go wrong
so fast talk to me
oh
my God
that's cool you don't break her
perspective because we already saw it we
know what's happening I'll let you in
that looks like he's he's dying
he's like transforming
looks like Jesse Eisenberg he hates it
when he died
you make him soft
so it's very evil dead
[Music]
oh you know don't blush
this is really sexually uncomfortable
I would I would stop this guys
I always rubber up against the ground
oh he's me
oh God Greg
stop it
oh that was the last thing I expected
oh that is so humiliating guys
oh yeah those are that was pretty heavy
yeah
so insensitive get your thought dog out
and no cameras
I've never seen a device like this in a
movie especially where it becomes like a
drug Escape
unbelievably well done I just like don't
know if I like it
[Music]
it's really uncomfortable yeah it's
really uncomfortable
but it's unbelievable
this Montage sequence is so necessary at
this point
[Music]
it's got this like cynical Macabre
madcap Behavior
[Music]
[Applause]
he does it again
[Music]
me too no way what if we did it for like
60 seconds you'd have to be a
about all things Riley wow you're just
so busy trying to suck Daniels don't
give a about anybody else wow why
do you want to do it so much to impress
James to come into my room crying that
you're scared like last time I hate you
like you're my favorite person in the
world
Dynamic strong
Mike actually kind of tense in the
shoulders I know yeah I don't know that
I've ever seen a move that made me like
this icky feeling 50 seconds yeah
let's go
you just get the feeling that something
truly terrible is about to happen at any
moment my hair is standing up on my arms
my shoulders actually hurt you better
not cry after 20 seconds that's how I
meant It's very effective talk to me
you say it
see someone he knows I'll let you win
[Laughter]
maybe he does choke to death or
something
I'm so sorry
whoa I never wanna hurt you
I miss you so oh it's her mom so much me
that was the same name this ain't fun
and games he doesn't want him to go
after 50 seconds gonna make him stay
longer
it's my mom please
damn
oh let it go
please don't leave him in there
oh no no no no no
get it off of him
oh god oh my god
no Greg Greg what happened
I think he did
oh my gosh
oh oh
okay
what's gonna happen to him
into the ghost of her mom
now please
oh and they weren't recording that one
were they did he rip his eye out I think
he like started to I'm not sure that's
kind of happening so fast I wish you
just be honest with me because you've
been so honest with me it means there's
something you haven't told me about mum
have we like never seen his face
it's kind of crazy the idea that she was
using this as like a form of escapism
from her pain and then it just comes
full circle to confront her but why
would the ghost haunting thing well
there was claws at the door so she
thought that her mom was trying to get
out but maybe the dad locked her in
there or something I don't know maybe
she's possessed
she took the hand and she's gonna do it
she's gonna try to reconnect with her
mom but she won't be able to she's gonna
perform to record it tell me he's okay
no offense I don't want you here right
now wait Jade
come on
I wouldn't have
um
no no did you give him something no
come on I know you've done before
what was it nothing else where it's not
true what did my son ever do to you
oh I didn't hurt him you did
as heavy as hell but that cinematography
is beautiful right now
hmm
[Music]
she like let out
remember her thing about the mirrors
yeah the reflections
it's really her mom or is it just tricks
on her own mind
I don't know to be honest it's so hard
to be upset with her because if I had a
way to talk to my mom I probably would
have done it too it's like I want to be
so annoyed with her because she didn't
pull him yeah but I love what a movie
does that you kind of debate about it in
your head I love that yeah it's just
wildly wildly well done so effective I
just like
can't deal with it I can't go home I
know something's out
doing spiral even more I don't want to
be alone
okay yikes this is the bad call she's
got like literally no one right now
maybe
because she was trying to reach out
she's gonna ask him to do it with her he
could check oh
I'm never doing it again man no the
spirit seem like they're trapped in
their like own grief cycle remember when
we hold down
and they could feel your heart beating
through your fingertips now this is
getting way too specific it's getting
way too specific it probably still no
way
oh guys
why don't they want to tell what
happened because they don't want the
hand to get taken away I mean they
probably wouldn't believe but at the
same time if they just did it edit like
cop just did everything in a court case
they would show that's real
suck my ass
as much as there's like this almost
nihilistic approach to the film there's
something about the relationships that
feel so far from what is conventionally
done in a film even right down to this
little interaction here with the mom and
daughter I really hope that her and that
boyfriend don't cross the line
right by the feet
that's the sequel
am I looking at a calf right now shin
I don't think I've ever seen a shot like
that what is that a person or no it's
her
oh
whoa cool
I mean this isn't cool this is a dream I
would assume so
in the room is that her dad
whoa
the fingernails
I wonder if she's getting slowly
possessed by her mom
there's not that long left in the movie
it's almost like a slice of Life yeah
right
who is this
he's gonna wake up and she's sucking on
his toes or something
it's her doing it right
[Music]
the nails on the door remember we don't
remember where they got the hand from
maybe she just did too much possession
well she was over the 90 seconds the
first time
is her dad not home I guess not so like
she's going down her mother's descent
she's gonna do it without anybody
this is a terrible idea
she just has to not let them in I think
and she could let it go
yeah always
[Music]
oh
don't ruin the moment
Riley needs help
that wasn't what I was expecting
what am I looking at oh and her and her
mom
oh no this poor kid what's gonna happen
right now
oh no
now he's still possessed
stop stop him
or is she possessed right now
oh
no why would she be possessed I don't
know you're right
oh God
this movie really gets out of your skin
it's not fun no it's not it's not fun
it's like a true like demented
deterioration like what is the lesson in
this movie just to Spook you don't mess
with that roof I want to give you a
lesson another be careful what you wish
for kind of what's it trying to say I
woke up and mayor was sucking my feet
so why would you be seeing your mom you
didn't even let her in I didn't like I
said I couldn't even say to people wait
who stuck it I got the hand off him he
um
the brother
can we talk to him well the brother
didn't die he actually thought he had
friends but you were using him we were
using him call A real friend would have
seen him up these guys are terrible they
still kept using it after that and
didn't tell anybody cool
it does feel like a metaphor for like
drugs on the bus yeah get on talk to him
his body should kick him out they get
weaker the longer the rain maybe it's
time you stop up people's lives
Joss what do you reckon yeah man you're
the worst worst I didn't say mayor
that was just you and then you let it go
for two minutes and then you
sleep with my boyfriend what the is
wrong with you
I wish that you didn't force yourself
into my family meal
oh
saying we do it again with Riley but
throughout the candle this time you want
him to do it again
they're treating the mom like she's like
like guiding her right to make this
choice but is the mom actually a
malevolent spirit I don't know you don't
know until we know what actually
happened with the mom we need the dad to
be honest about that and I keep
wondering why they don't show us the
Dad's face mom's like an hour
we'll be quick
I absolutely never want to watch this
again
I think it's excellent It's a harsh
experience yeah like it's very cold
how do you get him to say it talk to him
oh
he's got a requested himself what if I
use the hand to speak to him no what
he's not dead me but what if his spirit
is disconnected from his body or
something then disconnect Riley
talk to me
is there a boy here
whoa he's like this is like Insidious
oh
my God where are we going
[Applause]
he's getting eaten alive
and ass visual
not gonna stop you need to send Jade in
there
what would be the benefit of sending
Jade in there something with Jade it's
all to continue on JH it has another
moment Jade hasn't gone in something
with her she's the key
I haven't been completely honest with
you okay okay let's hear it what was it
she left or something
I'd be scared to show you which is which
is wrong of me it's zero idea can I read
it to you it's a letter why would you
not have shared this prior because it
means that she did herself which means
the person she's talking to isn't really
her mom it's the first time in a long
time I haven't felt hopeless I am full
of hope I hope you can find some peace
and knowing
I have no login page yeah okay
[Music]
she didn't do it because she told me
that
good
that's the message of the movie you
can't change the circumstances just
because you want them to be different
sorry about grief and she's trying to
get to this point of acceptance
it's not true
no
and the demons that you either accept or
you fight I'll be back promise me
promise
do not let her go do you believe the
letter yeah yeah obviously that's
reality why did you write it I didn't
your dad
dad what yeah
it's not Max it is her these are the
demons he's going to hurt you
[Music]
the hand
Riley can't stay there oh this is so
well done this is like with your
heads he needs to die
he needs to die it's the kangaroo moment
hahaha
that's not her dad
what is happening that's the demons yeah
yeah but her dad's clearly sitting
somewhere else
she's just thrashing herself around like
yeah I think so
[Music]
her dad's there though so he's gonna
come help
no she's gonna stab herself no yeah
that's what I'm worried about or she's
gonna hurt her dad when he comes into
oh no do not stab yourself
oh
[Music]
bummer this movie is a darker as hell
this is like some real a24 right
here just where do you go from there you
just killed your dad I would probably
just want to die right after that you
kill Riley or not it doesn't even make a
difference at this point Kate
are you okay no I know what to do oh no
you know I actually think he's getting
better
yeah I woke up for a second she fully
let the demons in oh she's gonna try to
kill him
show me what
to be here Jade no the demons are
disappearing from our brother on their
own he's weaning them off the more she
uses it the worse she gets it's as a
fascinating like drug addiction until
you see it without them yeah I it's just
like relentlessly oppression you got her
to leave so she can go kill her brother
yeah
[Music]
this part doesn't feel like drug
addiction at all it's just a scissors I
mean just like the messed up choices and
stuff you know yeah I hear you man
oh sorry no it's okay oh my God and
mom's gonna forgive her too it's gonna
be so mean I know I was mad you had
every right to be
no I don't she's killed her dad the one
on drugs Mia I'm so sorry that I blamed
you I know that you wouldn't do anything
to hurt him I love you guys
oh no
oh this movie and it means so much to
him that you were here
yes
figures it out way
I'm so sorry Greg she's gonna walk in
and see that the dad's dead and then
she's gonna know there's a problem at
the hospital
Craig oh no she's seeing his urine bag
filled with blood or something
oh
he's doing stuff foundries
oh no
thank you he's ours
oh all right some great makeup in this
man he's at the mom walk in I see oh no
oh no you saw
Greg it's just like torture
did she kill hers
drop it drop it I want to feel
[Applause]
kangaroo kangaroo the mercy kill
all right
he's alive Mia
Riley
where did she take him where's my son he
was in this room well it should be here
he's just here
the classroom
Jade it's your time to shine honey you
haven't had a moment
no
oh why why this method because she's
gonna try to kill herself too or
something I don't know
foreign
[Music]
forever
that's your rear Telltale sign
no
what was that I don't know oh she just
she's the deer Greg
tell me what happened
what happened damn she's able to just
get up
oh she's on the other side now she's the
demon oh she's looking at it right
[Music]
man visuals are strong yeah she's become
one of them
I'm gonna be so far behind
you got better and everything
no reflection she doesn't exist
[Music]
Ence
does that mean her dad lives yeah
yeah
yeah and it's gonna be her but who has
the hand
[Music]
Wicked
yeah they say talk to me it's gonna end
you just see her and done it's cool
it's going towards the light
yeah oh my God
all the way to the other side
I'll let you in
Hillary
pesto
oh damn where they gonna get to
I'll let you win
that's a great end dude a really good
ending that's a great ass end here I
mean it was an excellent movie they did
an excellent excellent Miranda Otto
that's the name of the girl what do I
know her from is it Gray's Anatomy or
something I think we should break it
down into categories and talk it like
that
I don't know what you mean so do you
tell me what you mean I mean like a week
ago the categories
acting
oh sure yeah what do you want to talk
about acting
this is an interesting thing that you're
doing yeah let's do it it'll help me
create video chapters what category you
want to talk to about you choose no what
it's your thing how about this how about
this
let's create categories on the spot and
then we'll choose that would be like me
saying I want to have an immigration
plan and then me saying you that you
have to pick which one that is exactly
what it's like but it's your it's your
plan man I'm following your lead now
okay directing acting writing music and
like directing following Compass like
cinematography and stuff and and writing
and I think writing director would
probably I think we should write a
directing act and uh start like I don't
know if this is actually gonna help but
this might throw us off I am so thrown
off I think I've thrown us off I feel
like I thought I was trying to help us
out and I think I just made it worse
start where you want to start
all right
all right so you wanted to start with
directions I think I think we should
start with our overall emotional
response that's usually what we do too I
know I feel like I thought I was gonna
make something more interesting here and
I just derailed
I am very impressed by it and similar to
how I feel about two very separate
movies
the way I felt about
hereditary and 13.
are like
this was such an uncomfortable
experience and I admire so much about it
I don't know when I would want to
re-watch it though because it's
it's so mean like it is a mean ass movie
and I and that's part of why I I there's
a like I I love it in a way where I I
also like I kind of want to stay away
from it for a while though because
because I love it from the craftsmanship
of what it did
and I and I love its commitment to just
how harsh it actually gets instead of
shying away from it
and everything around of what it would
have committed to like it is a committed
film and it's so well executed to the
point where it is doing
a lot of things that we might have seen
in other horror films like you can feel
it's love and adoration for other horror
movies like you get these sense of
things like hereditary uh Evil Dead and
uh Insidious like a lot of and I'm sure
a whole bunch of other ones as well
other possession films but it doesn't
feel derivative at the same time does it
feel like they're just aping it it still
feels like they're doing their own thing
which I really appreciated but the
experience itself just kind of left me
in a uh oh that
that's a tough one to sit through again
yeah you know yeah and that's sort of
where I I land on it I I will probably
one day watch it again but
um the movie's not having any it's not
fun yeah and I thought it might be a
little fun just because of like what I'm
familiar with their work being uh prior
and like you know even even for some
like they're not the same kind of
filmmakers at all or same kind of
creatives Prior but even if you look at
a movie like
get out they're still fun to be had with
get out despite how like dark it gets
and there's something you know
hereditary I wouldn't say for some
reason this this hit me on a harsher
level than like hereditary hereditary
was like yeah yeah this this I think
it's because people there's something
that felt so relatable and and uh more
communal because it starts off on a tug
and pull of Hope whereas like hereditary
just throws you into
it's just going to be super depressing
from beginning to end this is just like
strips you from I puts you in her
perspective it just strips you from it
you know I love when artists
set out to make something and then they
make the absolute best possible version
of their Vision yeah which was this it's
like clearly this is exactly what they
wanted to do and they did it at a very
elevated
um you know I know people hate the term
elevated horror but like they did it to
the 10th degree the performances the
cinematography all of the categories
they did it so well the dialogue
um the design just in general the sound
design too they did everything perfectly
the story they wanted to tell is a story
that I didn't need to hear like
if you asked me what are the best movies
of the year I would say this is one of
them if you ask me what are my favorite
movies of the year I would not say this
is one of them yeah there's like an
intellectual versus an emotional right
because I feel as if this is totally
this is horror horror this is like
with you to mess with you and like
really it it's not I'm not saying
there's no heart in it because of course
there's a family Dynamic but there was
no feel-good element at all and it like
you said it wasn't fun it was so dark
and so
um horrible to watch this experience
that it was interesting like I haven't
seen a movie that made me feel like that
in a really long time and since being on
this channel and just in the most recent
years I've been getting into horror for
the first time really I mean I grew up
watching a lot of the classics but I I
haven't been like a horror junkie and I
don't think I get I'm not easily spooked
even though some things really make me
my skin crawl but more like in a fun way
this the whole time watching it felt
like I felt horrible yeah no I did like
my shoulders have been tense this whole
time in a way that truly feels
unsettling and
there's like something crawling at my
soul in a weird way yeah and I
think that's what they wanted obviously
they want to make you uncomfortable and
I what that's what I liked about it
because
so oppressive and the
you know when you see a trailer for
something like this you're going to get
the horror you're going to get the
gimmicks you're gonna like that I don't
even really remember the trailer but
you'll you'll get you know the teases of
the the visuals and whatnot and while
there's some great visuals here what
what they Excel that is most movies I
think will kind of just rely on that and
the jump scares and spooks
this movie knew how to really get to you
on the like the creepiest of
psychological levels
and to do that in an efficient run time
as well
I don't know I keep bringing up
hereditary is like two and a half hours
or something it's a really long movie
this is 90 minutes it's a short tight
film but man does the experience feel
felt like you are this feels longer than
that in the way that I think they wanted
it to be because it's not boring
it just puts you into this like haunt
you know the Harry Potter movies the
mentors yeah kind of get that feeling
it's like soul sucking you know a couple
things number one because you guys know
I'm obsessed with the actors Miranda
Otto I feel like I can picture her with
Mandy pankin which is making me think
that she was in Homeland that might be
where I'm knowing her most from the
redhead the mom which I definitely know
her number two
um I don't know what I was what number
two was I was so focused on Miranda Otto
maybe if I had your categories
um yeah yeah well the cast uh what'd you
think of the uh the main girl like Mia
they were all great I thought they were
all great I I can't distinguish one from
the other being better or worse they
were all effing amazing like truly every
single one of them I thought even like
the the Entourage of people I know that
you really really were harping on me as
performance which I think she did
amazing but
um she had a lot to do and she was given
the most to do the fact that I thought
some of the other actors that were given
almost nothing to do yeah did made such
powerful impacts
like
um like Jade
um or like the boyfriend or like the
best the two that had the hand
um I just think that they all were so
good on nothing
yeah it relies a lot on just natural
personality and natural chemistry yes
and I think the the performers felt they
felt like real friends they felt like
the people who really knew each other it
didn't feel like what's this archetype
cast what's his heart type put them
there they really seem like
I don't know I I I don't know if the
filmmakers uh knew these people
beforehand and just put them on screen
you know together to play The Ensemble
because yeah The Ensemble was perfectly
cast
that helped Elevate the experience of
being able to watch them on screen
because a lot of those dudes the guys
specifically are so unlikable the the
guy's in charge of the hand one of them
was a dude
two or three of them right the black guy
and then the other guy I just I didn't
think that that was like well I don't
know what their pronouns are oh I'm not
sure though
I'm unclear I thought it was a guy I'm
not sure you could be totally right okay
um maybe that's me being the and you
being the woke Roxy that you are
um it's possible
um no no no you're being respectful I
appreciate it maybe
um I'm not sure if I am or I'm not
trying to play Both Sides you're either
a woke crazy liberal or no you're being
respectful
that's crazy
yeah I don't know oh yeah I really
really don't know the ending was
phenomenal the beginning was phenomenal
they really like they tell you what's
gonna happen yeah they tell you right at
the beginning like that's why I love it
at the beginning they keep you from an
observer and then the ending they put
you in her because you're in her
perspective yeah you know as as two
people who have grieved before it is
interesting like the way
what we've only grieved just once no
no yeah two people agreed before yeah
I've agreed once
two people have creeped several times
before
um I think that you do have weird
thought processes sometimes and I think
that that this movie did really go into
some of that like what do you believe
what don't you believe your mind
certainly plays tricks on you reality
plays tricks on you
um or or like your perception of reality
right right this did a very good job of
capturing that with through a lens that
they created oh I remember what I was
going to say earlier was that I really
love that this set its rules and then
played by the rules yeah like we knew
that you had to say talk to me and that
is when you could talk to them and then
I let you in is when that happened then
they use that exact rule to get her to
go to the other side with the little
girl at the end which was really smart
we knew about like that there was the
candle situation we knew we needed to be
in there under 90 seconds or there was
going to be an issue and we knew that we
didn't know exactly where they were
coming from kind of like that Heath
Leisure one how I got these scars we
didn't know whether it was a Satanist or
whether it was a medium or what but that
wasn't the point right it was that
there's something in there that has
connection to the outside and that was
always what the case was and that this
has been passed around and passed around
they let us know also that the longer
they're in you the more likely you can
see them afterwards and then you might
be screwed they said the the further
space there is after they're gone if you
just let them go then eventually you'll
be okay like they really set up all the
things that sometimes I feel like lazy
writing doesn't do where you'll be like
wait but why does this hand work like
where'd they get what are you not going
to address that they really laid out for
us without spoon feeding us and it took
its time they laid out for us all the
their world and how this works and then
they didn't break their rules because it
was convenient they played by those
rules just really really smart
storytelling and I think the rules
you're absolutely right completely agree
and I think the rules
complement
the the themes and the psychological
digression of the characters very well
like I do think it's I do think there's
a lot of here that's it's so much about
like the theme of Disconnect seemed very
apparent she's always trying to connect
people or on their phones ignoring her
she's ignoring her dad and so much of
this was like if she just dealt with her
own
which is easier said than done but if
she had if she had grieved and except
accepted she wouldn't have gone down
this route of escapism and I don't know
what the intention on the filmmakers was
exactly but to me it did feel like when
people are in a lot of pain and
suffering and they'd be go down the path
of like drug addiction in some way and
they they find a vice to hide from their
pain and problems and how that can
contort to manipulate and lead you down
to these terrible choices in life and
then look where it ends up makes makes
you end up landing at and I loved that
it was just so much more deeper Nuance
like I I really love the movie I really
appreciated it so much it's just the
ride
the ride is tough to be on that's one of
those things I have a question for you
though about as I'm going through all
the moments in this
why was there claw marks on the door
if her mom killed herself
uh
uh maybe because in the final Heat of
the Moment she actually didn't want to
you know that thing was like the split
session they were too late
or maybe she didn't like maybe maybe she
actually was
telling the truth in some way no I
definitely think she wasn't because of
that letter and what was painted to be
but the mom okay yeah this is the demons
do impersonate right
yeah but sometimes the demons are the
actual thing because like she becomes
like the actual ghost at the end so
she's not a demon but she's like a ghost
Mia I think she's maybe or she's a demon
yeah he's too far so she would have the
capability of impersonating yeah but she
doesn't
or does we are seeing it from one
perspective who knows what she's looking
like to them
I think on the directing too they got a
brilliant handle on perspective because
this is like yeah all like for them for
the there's rare times where you cut
away from Mia but what Mia's in the room
it's on her perspective yeah every time
I agree with you that they have a really
good grip on it and I would watch any
movie they put out once yeah like
there's nothing they could put out that
I would be like I'm not watching that
and I would recommend this movie to
people yeah I just will not sit through
it again and the editing is so sharp
yeah there's parts of it that remind me
of like the the first the Precision of
of it of an Edgar Wright you know I I
loved I loved A lot of it I really did
who do you feel like will like this like
is it certain files like horror Jeff
Snyder uh really Dead Merle really yeah
um not just horror junk like you don't
think this is for like specifically for
the horror nuts you think this is just
what people love good scripts I think
yeah I think so yeah because I think
it's very character driven and it's
really smart it's it's a really smart
movie that while it uses the brutality
of in the violence and does The
Possession horror stuff it it it's more
on the respectable character-driven
narratives of a film like an exorcist in
a way where it's I don't think I saw
that that's really long
I'm not as in love with it as everyone
else but uh it's really good it's really
good but I'm like yeah yeah this is
really really good really good what do
you think the budget on this was I don't
know It's gotta be small though man but
I I mean again I'm just so like it's so
cool to see two two dudes who came from
YouTube yeah they didn't have that many
locations like no no it's on their
Hometown other than Miranda Otto I
didn't recognize anybody and they really
like wow they were very smart about how
they spent their time and money in this
I also noticed this like unique
production design Touch where everything
was so shadowed and dark like everything
was lit very very dark but they on the
the outfits that people were wearing
they usually had I didn't quite
understand the choice but man does it
draw your eye like sheep Mia was always
in this bright yellow there'd be another
scene where it's really dark but Jaden
this bright pink shirt they they managed
to make their characters still pop in
these environments Greg are you trying
to justify not having me wear my black
sweater yeah because it was too dark for
this yes we needed the thumbnail colors
and the black just makes it way too dark
and I'm still in Black so I know but
your skin how tone helps bounce it out
what are you calling me white oh are
Jews white yeah well not all but I am
you'd be considered white you're tanned
right now yeah well sometimes the sun's
out we do live in Southern California
Roxy's like toothpaste
[Music]
um see now this movie made me
that's what happened that's why yeah
this movie it's the movie on that note
uh Greg final thoughts other thoughts
um going through the rest of your
categories music solid perfectly dread
heavy totally mm-hmm yep performances
the direction the dialogue I know we
referenced a few times
the editing really solid everything
across the board it was like tons across
the board honestly yeah really good I
like the uh sexual deviant
uncomfortableness of moments too dogs I
think I I love the com again I just love
the commitment to how icky and gross it
is without being
without being indulgent for Indulgence
sake you know some movies just try too
hard like let's just go excessive
because that's all we know how to do
without any real deeper context in this
movie knew how to find that deeper
context in a way that's why it worked
because the demons could see he's
sexually repressed yeah I think that was
I think every choice was calculated yeah
and uh and that's why I'm like no I
wouldn't change a thing about it just
it's hard to sit there yeah yeah totally
okay well thanks for talking to me I'm
glad that I talked at you
you talked with me
thanks for listening
uh no do you have to pee or we shouting
somebody out no no there's people at the
door waiting what yeah yeah there's
other people who are going to film oh
for sure we'll talk to you soon and
thank you for being here don't forget
like comment subscribe five minutes late
they're both five minutes late middle of
telling everybody goodbye Greg that's
crazy
okay so you're going to find them too
just like it's just worked out because
that's it's about to be the time they're
gonna be here and I just I didn't even
know they were for sure at the door
do you want to say bye to them or no I
just love hanging out with you so much
that I was just willing to let them wait
out there for 25 minutes no it's high
five
this is like a 1980s
I think we can like I think we can um
Freeze Frame It Like an 80s movie over
here wait hold on hold on let me put
down my teeth okay hold on hold on hold
on everyone don't rush me okay where are
we looking
at the people yeah okay ready three two
one
[Music]
really good okay thanks for talking to
me and listening to us and all that good
stuff and we'll see you next time and
not feel as icky sleep well check under
your bed
[Music]